EVERYBODY AND WELCOME.
TO OUR VETERAN AFFAIRS --
COMMITTEE MEETING AND WE ARE
GOING TO BE HEARING TO BILLS
TODAY AND WE HAVE ONE BILL ON%
CONSENT WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
RIGHT NOW SO CAN I THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IRWIN HERE VOEPEL [inaudible]
BOERNER HORVATH [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
FRAZIER.
GLORIA.
MATHIS [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI.
PETRIE-NORRIS SALAS.
AND WHEN IT.
ALL RIGHT AND CAN I HAVE
SOMEBODY PLEASE OF MOVE THE
CONSENT S. J. R. SEVEN GLAZIER.
ALL RIGHTS -- BY THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AS CHAIR SEVEN THE MOTION IS BE
ADOPTED IRWIN.
I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I BURNER **** Và.
BRO [inaudible]
DALY.
DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I AM MURATSUCHI.
PETRIE-NORRIS SALAS.
AND SIX ZERO ALL RIGHT.
NOW WE ARE JUST WAITING. FOR
SENATOR UMBERG AND SENATOR
MORALE IF ANYBODY HAS A PHONE
AND WOULD LIKE TO MESSAGE THEM
[inaudible]
AB.
MAYBE THERE WHAT IS YOUR MAYOR
.
US THIS YEAR SEVEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SALAS.
ASSEMBLY WERE SALAS AYE
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS OF PRESENT --
SB FIVE HUNDRED SENATOR OF
MORALES.
THE BILL AND WE HAVE --
WITNESSES SUPPORT OR STAFF
MEMBER.
WHAT OF OKAY [inaudible]
YOUR SALAS.
THANK YOU WILSHIRE PRESENT SB
FIVE HUNDRED IS A PLAN TO EXPAND
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES FOR STATES
RETURNING DISABLED VETERANS.
I DO HAVE -- WOULD JUST AS HERE
IN SUPPORT AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE.
THE WITNESSES PLEASE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OF FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
FOR ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS IN ARMS.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE THE BANKS IN A
ROW AND A HOST OF OTHER SENATORS
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN INTRODUCING SUCH
A TREMENDOUS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
DESIGNED TO HELP THE VETERANS OF
CALIFORNIA.
MY NAME IS CLAIRE IS THE LIST
AND I AM A DISABLED VETERAN.
I'M SORRY I'M A DISABLED
AIRFORCE VETERAN AND I AM ALSO
RESIDENT CALIFORNIA.
I HAD THE HONOR OF CENTER
SERVING THE WORLD'S GREATEST AIR
AND SPACE POWER. FOR A PERIOD OF
ELEVEN YEARS AND NINE MONTHS.
I SERVED IN OPERATION IRAQI
FREEDOM OPERATION DOING FREEDOM
AND TWO CONSECUTIVE TOURS AND
REPUBLIC OF KOREA.
BY SO MANY OF MY OF MY BROTHERS
AND SISTERS IN ARMS.
BECAME A CRESSMAN A CRESSMAN A
PERFORMING MY DUTIES IN THE
ATMOSPHERE OF CLEAR AND PRESENT
DANGER.
LIKE SO MANY OF OUR BROTHERS AND
SISTERS IN ARMS THE SUM OF ALL
THOSE FEARS WERE FORMING A CLAMP
PRESIDENT JR PALE IN COMPARISON
TO THE FAIR REJOINING OUR
BELOVED COUNTRY AS A CIVILIAN.
BECOMING A CIVILIAN AGAIN AS
HARD BECAUSE OF THE THINGS WE
MAY HAVE HAVE WE MAY HAVE GONE
THROUGH OUT WE SERVED.
THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT COIN IS
THAT OUR WARTIME IN PEACE TIME
DUTIES ARE NONTRANSFERABLE TO
THE CIVILIAN SECTOR.
THIS MEANS THAT IN ORDER TO
SURVIVE AFTER SERVING WE HAVE TO
GO BACK TO COLLEGE.
THE MAJORITY OF HAT THE MAJORITY
OF US HAVE THE GI BILL WHICH IS
SUFFICIENT FORCE TO COMPLETE OUR
BATCHES AGREE.
BUT IN MANY CASES THAT DOES NOT
MAKE US COMPATIBLE CUT
COMPETITIVE ENOUGH TO SCORE THE
GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT WE NEED TO
SUSTAIN FOR OUR FAMILIES.
THIS DIRECTLY MEANS THAT IN
ORDER FOR SOME VETERANS TO BE
TRULY COMPETITIVE ENOUGH
WORKFORCE WE MUST ACHIEVE HIGHER
THAN A BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
WHEN IT COMES TO ACHIEVING
HIGHER THAN A BASS IS AGREED
NORMALLY A VETERAN HAS EXHAUSTED
OR NEARLY EXHAUSTED ALL OF THEIR
GI BILL?
THIS IS WHERE THE VOCATIONAL
REHAB BUT REHABILITATION COMES
INTO PLAY AND IT CAN PROVIDE THE
LAST BLUES A VETERAN NEEDS TO
ACHIEVE THAT COMPETITIVE EDGE
FOR GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT.
ALTHOUGH A LARGE NUMBER OF
VETERANS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
VOCATIONAL REHAB NOT ALL
VETERANS CAN AND RECEIVE THE
ENTITLEMENT OF OCCASIONAL REHAB.
AND THAT IS WHY WE ARE HERE
TODAY.
WE ARE HERE BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S
VETERANS IS OVER YES AT THE DAY
HAVE BEEN TOLD NO.
WE ARE HERE FOR CALIFORNIA
VETERANS WHO NEED TO COMPLETE OR
ACHIEVE THEIR HIGHER DEGREE BUT
CAN'T RECEIVE THE BACKING THEY
NEED FROM VOCATIONAL REHAB.
LET US BE REALISTIC.
SB FIVE HUNDRED IS THE FINAL
SAVING GRACE.
THAT ONLY A FEW VETERANS WILL
NEED ALTHOUGH OF ACTUAL ALTHOUGH
BACHELOR DEGREES ARE THE NORM
NOT EVERY VETERAN WILL NEED
HIGHER THAN A BACHELOR'SDEGREE.
AND MOST VETERANS NEED HIGHER
THAN A BASS IT'S AGREE WILL BE
HELPED BY VOCATIONAL REHAB.
SB FIVE HUNDRED IS THE YES WHEN
THE LAST OF US HAVE BEEN TOLD NO.
THIS JUST MEANS THAT EVEN THOUGH
WE CAN NO LONGER BE HEROES FOR
OUR COUNTRY WE CAN BE HEROES FAR
FAMILIES.
WHEN THE AVERAGE BETTER RETURNS
TO THE CIVILIAN SECTOR HERE SHE
RETURNS WITH THE FAMILY?
A MONTHS THE STRAIN OF
DISABILITY WHO SCARS ARE SEEN
AND UNSEEN.
THE NEED TO PROVIDE FOR ONE'S
FAMILY IN SPITE OF INJURY AND
THE DISADVANTAGE OF TIME IS
PARAMOUNT.
AGAIN SB FIVE HUNDRED IS THAT
SAVING GRACE THAT SUPPORTS THE
VETERAN'S FAMILY WHILE THE
VETERAN BECOMES WHAT HE OR SHE
NEEDS TO BE FOR THEIR FAMILY.
SB FIVE HUNDRED IS A YES TO THE
VETERAN AND HIS FAMILY OR HER
FAMILY WHEN ALL OTHER AVENUES
HAVE BEEN DEPLETED.
AND AND NO AND NO.
ONE AND NO WAS THOUGHT TO BE THE
FINAL ANSWER.
GOD BLESS YOU ALL GOD BLESS
CALIFORNIA GOD BLESS AMERICA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT --
TESTIMONY AND DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER -- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
YES GOOD AFTERNOON DAN AND
NICKEL WITH READ GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN GI A FORMER CALIFORNIA.
TOWN VETS DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA'S TAKE MATTERS
VETERANS COUNCIL MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION AMERICAN
NATIONAL GUARD ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA THE VIETNAM VETERANS
OF AMERICA.
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS AND A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAILY
BY THE I'M SORRY SENATOR MORRELL
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I'VE DONE SO MUCH.
HEY I JUST WANT TO THANK --
ASSEMBLYMAN MATHIS FOR BEING A
CO AUTHOR AND FOR SALAS FOR
STEPPING IN FOR ME TODAY HAD TO
YOU VERY GREAT THANK YOU GET AND
GREAT TESTIMONY AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
VERY VERY GOOD NO I'M JUST GOING
TO ASK FOR AND I BUT I THINK.
I PROBABLY I PROBABLY WOULD A
RULING THAT IF I WOULD HAVE I
SPOKEN SO.
I'LL JUST ASK FOR AND I BUILDING
SAY THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU ROLL PLEASE.
SB FIVE HUNDRED THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED -- WHEN -- WHEN
I VOEPEL?
VOEPEL AYE BURNER MORE ABOUT.
BRO.
DALY DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
I MATHIS.
MATHIS I A MURATSUCHI
[inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I SALAS.
SALAS AYE. SEVEN ZERO RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND NEXT UP WE HAVE SENATOR
UMBERG -- SB [inaudible]
FOUR EIGHT ONE WITHIN SECONDS.
ALL RIGHT WELL I AM MODE OLD
LAWYERS SO WHEN I HAVE A
TENTATIVE IT'S IN MY FAVOR THEN
I KNOW TO BE QUIET BUT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
MIKE MY I'M GUESSING THAT YOU
YOU WANT ME TO ACTUALLY RESPOND
SO -- YOU HAVE A FEW WORDS TO
SAY TO THANK YOU PERSONAL THANK
YOU TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF.
THE BILL WAS NEARLY PERFECT AND
NOW IT'S PERFECT WELL EXCEPT FOR
A COUPLE SMALL EXCEPTIONS.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE HELP AND
ASSISTANCE AND GUIDANCE YOUR
STEPS PROVIDED -- THE WORK ON
THIS BILL REALLY BEGIN A TWO
THOUSAND FIVE WITH RESPECT TO
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL MAKING
SURE THAT THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA NATIONAL
GUARD MILITARY DEPARTMENT
ACTUALLY PROVIDES THE KIND OF
OVERSIGHT INSPECTION THAT ONE
WOULD EXPECT.
AND SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
PROVIDES THAT CERTAIN COMPLAINTS
WOULD GO TO THE GOVERNOR AS
OPPOSED TO JUST THE THE THE TAG.
AND ALSO PROVIDES FOR CERTAIN
PROVISIONS WITH RESPECT TO
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTIONS IN
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS -- THE THE
COMMITTEE HAS SUGGESTED THAT
THAT -- THERE A COUPLE ISSUES
WITH THE BILL ONE ISSUE IS IT
BEGINS BY SAYING AT THE
DISCRETION OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL CERTAIN.
INSPECTIONS ARE MANDATED AND WE
DO NEED TO FIX THAT AND WE'LL
HAVE BE FIXED IT AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD.
MADAM CHAIR OF IT IF YOU WOULD
BE SO KIND THE COMMITTEE SO KIND
AS TO PERMIT THE BILL TO MOVE
FORWARD -- IN IN ALSO -- THERE'S
BEEN A SUGGESTION THAT WE CHANGE
THE SHALL TO MAY WITH RESPECT TO
MANDATE INSPECTIONS -- THE THE
THE WORD SHALL IS INTENTIONAL SO
THAT FOR EXAMPLE FOR MEMBER
LEGISLATURE -- REQUEST
INSPECTION BE DONE THAT THAT
INSPECTION ACTUALLY DONE OF
COURSE INSPECTOR GENERAL -- CAN
DEVOTE WHATEVER TIME AND EFFORT
HERE SHE DEEMS IS APPROPRIATE
FOR THAT AND ALSO THE OTHER
ISSUE IS WITH RESPECT -- TO AN
ALLEGATION BY MEMBER THE GENERAL
PUBLIC -- THAT THAT NEED NOT
NECESSARILY BE -- INVESTIGATED
THAT IS UP TO THE DISCRETION OF
OF THE INSPECTOR GENERAL BUT
CERTAINLY A MEMBER THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT MAKES ALLEGATION
ABOUT FOR EXAMPLE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT I WANT
MANDATED INSPECTED -- AND THEN
THE AGAIN THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
HERE SHE CAN DEVOTE THE TIME AND
EFFORT ATTENTION AS DEEMED
NECESSARY.
ALL RIGHT UP MISTER BARTH IS
HERE -- AS WITNESS BE HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO QUESTIONS BART GIVE
ANYTHING YOU WANTED THANK
SEARCHES AND WANTED TO CONFIRM --
ALSO THAT THE NATIONAL GUARD
ASSOCIATION -- SUPPORTS THE THE
BILL BUT I'D BE AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS.
I CERTAINLY AND DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER -- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WE IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ANY QUESTIONS [inaudible]
REMEMBER VOEPEL.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL IT'S A VERY
GOOD BILL BUT I DID HAVE A MINOR
NON LAWYER QUESTION.
AND THAT IS -- CURRENTLY UNDER
EXISTING LAW SAYS MAKES THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL A PRINCIPAL
ADVISER TO THE GOVERNOR AND THE
ADJUTANT GENERAL.
AND THEN -- THIS BILL CHANGES IT
TO MAKES THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
AN ADVISER TO THE GOVERNOR.
pGENERAL WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
THE DIFFERENCE IS IS THAT WHAT
WE WANT TO DO IS IS WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
ACTUALLY REPORTS THE COMMANDER
IN CHIEF GOVERNOR BEING THE
COMMANDER IN CHIEF OF THE
NATIONAL GUARD AS OPPOSED TO THE
OF THE TAG.
OKAY THANK YOU.
SHOULD DEBT AND THEN THE OTHER
THING IS JUST SIMPLY.
MY LAST HELD RANK WAS IN THE SIX
OKAY SO I'M OBVIOUSLY A COMMAND
EXPERT FOR THE MILITARY RIGHT.
SO IS MY EXPERIENCE THAT EASE
SIXES ARE COMMAND EXPERTS ON
HOME RIGHT [inaudible]
SO.
THIS IS -- BASED.
IN A SOMEWHAT ORDERED INCIDENT
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN I WON'T GO
INTO THE DETAILS IN THE
CALIFORNIA AIR NATIONAL GUARD
HAVE THERE BEEN OTHER INSTANCES
SENSE THEN.
SO -- SOME A MEMBER VOEPEL THIS
ACTUALLY WAS BASED ON EFFORTS
THAT I BEGIN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIVE OF MUCH PRIOR TO THE
INCIDENT THAT YOU READ ABOUT IN
THE IN THE NEWSPAPER -- I'M NOT
SURE BUT THE THE ISSUE IS NOT
ABOUT -- ONE PARTICULAR INCIDENT --
AND MEAN.
TO MAKE SURE THAT I AM CLEAR I I
THINK NATIONAL GUARD IS WELL LED
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- AND
SO.
THIS IS -- AN EFFORT TO IMPROVE
THE SYSTEM.
FROM YOU KNOW STARTING IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE AND HOPEFULLY
CONTINUING FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE.
ROGER THAT SIR MADAM CHAIR --
DONE RIGHT -- THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE -- ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS
SIR I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
KEEPING IT AS A SHALLOW INSTEAD
OF A MAY -- DEALING WITH
GOVERNMENT WITHOUT THE SHALL.
ON PEOPLE TEND TO BE --
COMPLACENT AND NOT ACTUALLY DO
IT SO KEEPING THAT SHALL
VENTURES THAT THINGS WILL
ACTUALLY BE DONE.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS AND A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBERS SALAS
WE HAD SUGGESTED -- THAT CHANGE
WORD CHANGE BUT IT WAS -- IN
THIS CASE TRULY A SUGGESTION AND
I'M STILL HAPPY TO RECOMMEND --
TO PASS EVEN IF YOU DON'T TAKE
THAT.
TO THAT AMENDMENT SO -- WOULD
YOU DO YOU HAVE ANY FINAL WORDS
FELL.
IN APPRECIATE THIS AGO AND I IS
A BEGIN I SAID THAT THE WITH
YOUR STAFF AND AND YOU HAD
IMPROVE THE BILL AND I
APPRECIATE THAT AS WELL ARJUN I
WILL.
CERTAINLY -- CAN WE DO THE ROLE
PLEASE.
SB FORTY ONE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS -- WHEN I --
WHEN I VOEPEL VOEPEL I BOERNER
HORVATH?
BRO.
DALY HI DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA I MATHIS.
MATHIS I AM MURATSUCHI. THREE
NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I SALAS.
SALAS AYE SEVEN ZERO AND
CONGRADULATIONS THAT BILL EXAM
THANK YOU MANAGER.
NUMBER [inaudible]
WE OF WE WILL GO AHEAD AND HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS
VOTE ON THE REST OF THE BILLS
ARE WHAT DO WE DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY ELSE I WALKED IN I JUST.
OKAY.
AND EXPERIENCE SEVENTY THREE
NORTH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE CALENDAR THAT THAT'S YEAH
[inaudible]
YEAH.
JOHN NAM IS PHENOMENAL.
LEADERS IN THE
YEAH DOESN'T SAY.
ALI RELATION [inaudible]
SO THAT'S YEAH